C
[Música]
Boa noite a todos é um prazer estar com
vocês novamente eu tô sem o meu
microfone que eu tava usando aí
habitualmente eh paraas lives anteriores
Então eu queria que vocês me dessem o
feedback do áudio Como está o áudio pra
gente poder dar seguimento Ok vejo que
Rinaldo já tá ao vivo Boa noite Rinaldo
Carlos kman
Eliane obrigado pela presença de vocês
bem vou dividir a
tela com as
perguntas este aqui mesmo
pronto não mas não era essa aqui aqui
não pera
aí
deix só um minuto que eu tô muuito
janela aberta aqui no meu computador tá
um pouco confuso aqui para mim só um
minutinho acho que é esse aqui
pronto primeira pergunta você pode falar
a respeito da terapia por oxigênio
molecular Deixa eu só mudar aqui a
configuração pronto
fica mais fácil de ver vou tirar meu
rosto deixar só a tela
mesmo eu acho que você quis dizer
hidrogênio molecular porque eu tava
olhando as perguntas e logo em seguida
você tá perguntando sobre hidrog
molecular Tá mas V falar um pouquinho
sobre oxigênio existe a terapia de vene
né que é você fazer atividade física
com oxigênio em altas doses
eu acho que é essa que você tá querendo
dizer ou a de hidrogênio molecular Mas
vamos lá então a terapia com oxigênio
altas doses em conjunto com exercício é
muito benéfico para melhorar a
circulação arterial tá vai ajudar em
situações para melhorar doenças
pulmonares obstrutivas crônicas
pneumonia insuficiência Cardia
congestiva vai ajudar na circulação
cerebral né então é uma terapia muito
interessante com oxigênio em atividade
com exercício físico em conjunto tá
então o protocolo de varden que é bem
interessante já a terapia com hidrogênio
molecular né que eu já falei em lives
anteriores Então é bom você dar ol na
minha Live sobre hidrogênio molecular
são duas lives tem no canal tá então
utiliza o hidrogênio molecular Devido as
suas propriedades antioxidantes o
hidrogênio éa capaz de neutralizar os
radicais lives ele protege as células
contra estess oxidativo protege o DNA
isso vai ajudar a prevenir o
envelhecimento celular reduzir o stress
oxidativo diminuir a
inflamação então você pode tanto fazer a
inalação do
hidrogênio uma máquina que Produza junto
com o oxigênio ou você fazer ingestão de
água hidrogenada vai ser benéfico para
várias condições como infecções de modo
geral reduzir sintomas por exemplo de
pacientes com covid-19
melhora da Resistência redução da Fadiga
Então vai ter uma série de benefícios
interessantes próxima pergunta luz
vermelha LED 5 v tem algum problema você
disse certa vez que entre o LED e o
fluorescente era melhor o LED eu
expliquei isso né na na Live que eu que
eu falei disso mas vamos
lá a questão sobre problemas com as
lâmpadas
LED especialmente aquelas com baixa
voltagem com de 5
v geralmente não tá relacionado a
aspectos
médicos mas sim a questões técnicas de
instalação mas sim as lâmpadas LED elas
são preferíveis em comparação com outras
opções como as lâmpadas fluorescentes ou
incandescentes porque as leds consomem
menos energia em relação a incandescente
fluorescente Elas têm uma longa
durabilidade durando até 50 vezes mais
que as lâmpadas incandescentes e elas
emitem menos radiação ultravioleta tá
então em termos de saúde a vantagem da
led é que ela não emite radiação
ultravioleta que ao contrário a
fluorescente ela Pode emitir pequenas
quantidade de radiação
UV Além disso as lâmpadas LED não tem
mercúrio então se você romper uma uma
lâmpada fluorescente você pode se
contaminar com
Mercúrio certo então eu espero ter
respondido a sua pergunta aqui a próxima
pergunta gostaria de saber a respeito da
terapia com hidrogênio molecular tá já
comentamos sobre isso como eu falei acho
que a pergunta com o oxigênio foi um
pouco equivocada né então novamente é
uma terapia antioxidante
antiinflamatória você pode tá utilizando
hidrogênio tanto na forma inalada quanto
na forma ingerida Ok por ser um
antioxidante muito leve que passa por
todas as barreiras celulares ele não tem
nenhum impedimento de penetrar em cada
célula do corpo inclusive na mitocôndria
e isso é muito interessante porque
facilita a ação do hidrogênio molecular
na sua ação antioxidante Então ele pode
ajudar a reduzir inflamação combater o
câncer aliviar dores aliviar
desconfortos articulares e musculares e
promover a saúde cardiovascular e
cerebral e também é útil no tratamento
do covid
Ok se você tiver ao vivo eu posso dar
mais informações específicas se for o
caso
tomar quantos comprimentos ser Marina
por dia para adultos e qual é o melhor
horário isso é variável tá a dose mínima
da cim Marina seria 500 mg por dia
tá mas você pode tomar até em gramas a
silimarina você pode tomar entre 500 mg
até 2 g por dia de
silimarina e é bom você distribuir essa
a silimarina ao longo do dia você pode
tomar 500 mg por exemplo no Café 500 mg
no almoço e no jantar caso você queira
tomar 1,5 g por dia
certo então a dose é essa de 500 mg até
2 g por
dia D Alan várias vezes eu tentei
comprar suplementos para ela integ
gritar
eles pedem receita fica estranho pois
Dizem que o frete grátis é só para os
pacientes e nem todos que admiramos seu
trabalho já nos consultamos com o senhor
por diversos
motivos eu acho quis dizer que nem todos
que admiram o meu trabalho CONSEG
consultar comigo
né mas apesar dis se sempre conseguir
comprar como por exemplo beber 500 mg
para reduzir açúcar eles nunca mais
pediram nada mas eu estou querendo
comprar 15000 ade de vitamina D e 150
mic de K2 eles estão pedindo a receita é
por causa da dose tá essa dose de
vitamina D tá alta
Ok e a minha vitamina D está em 39 ela
não tá tão baixa n tá bem razoável né
Tem algum problema então se você tomar
15.000 unidades de vitamina D direto sem
fazer exame de sangue você pode ficar
com hipervitaminose D sim tá eu não
recomendo que você faça isso sem ver
exame o senhor poderia ia falar com eles
autorizando pessoas que são da
comunidade fechada já eu já fiz isso tá
eles não devem ter autorizado o seu caso
porque você tava pedindo uma dose muito
alta e caso a dose seja alta eles mandam
alguma mensagem Sim eu já falei para
eles mandarem talvez no seu caso aí eles
não fizeram por algum motivo vou
procurar saber tá Eu pretendo me
consultar com o senhor em breve
confiando em Deus Ok eh deixa eu ver
quem que mandou essa
mensagem foi Antônio Renato tá antô eu
vou fazer o
seguinte eu vou pedir licença rapidinho
para vocês aqui eu vou mandar uma
mensagem para eles
agora pode
entrar fiz assim não sei se você vai
Obrigado querida dá para dar uma
aliviada ah deixa aqui an
Renato pediu receita de vitamina D
15.000
unidades por dia
e do grupo de
apoiadores tá Depois aí ela me responde
Amanhã a gente vê isso daí tá
bom para despara posso fazer algum
protocolo tomando medicamento alopático
sim pode o ideal mesmo aquele protocolo
de fórmulas
manipuladas sim você pode usar um ou
outro tá bom Eu particularmente eu não
tenho assim essa paixão tão grande
Tá pelo protocolo da ruda clar eu uso
aqui no consultório mas eu acho que é
bendazol EV mectina e aitas oxida eles
são bons parasitários eu tenho muito
pouco problema com eles de efeito
colateral tá então eu diria para
você que não vejo o problema de você
utilizar ou as tinturas lá da de
Cravinho da rud da Clark né ou mesmo
utilizar gengibre
e Semente de abóbora semente de mamão tá
eles têm propriedades antiparasitárias
também mas eu geralmente eu prefiro
passar os antiparasitários de fassa que
eu acho que é mais simples Tá mas não
tem nenhum vejo nenhum problema se eu
usar orégano tintura de Cravinho tintura
de absinto aquelas coisas que tem no
protocolo da da ruda clarque
tá
Ah tem uma pergunta da Kelly ao vivo
aqui estou ao vivo eu gostaria de saber
se o hidrogênio molecular ajudaria em
caso de demência sim ajudaria falei a
agora a pouco viu Kelly assiste a minha
Live tá as duas lives que eu fiz sobre
hidrogênio molecular no meu canal tá bem
completa As
lives Olha
só prazer meu viu Roberta prazer meu
vocês estão me ouvindo bem
né ninguém me deu feedback da minha o
volume tá bom ou não tá bom daí vamos
continuar Enquanto vocês não respondem
dout Alan Você tem uma lista de médicos
tenho tá eu vou digitar aqui para
vocês a lista de médicos É
luta.com bar indicações
Ok isso eu publiquei isso
aqui no
passado mas pode ser que eu vou até
mostrar para vocês
aqui eu vou mudar a tela
aqui
pronto eu vou parar aqui a e vou colocar
de novo aqui só que eu vou mostrar a
outra
tela pronto
ó é isso aqui tá ó médicos recomendados
no Brasil que trabalham com a medicina
integrativa
aí tem um vídeo antigo que eu tenho aqui
tá até tô até no escuro aqui nesse
vídeo ó tá vendo os nomes aqui ó são
médicos que eu recomendo no
Brasil
beleza vamos de
novo próxima pergunta
caro Doutor a benfotiamina é
lipossolúvel mas na
bula que indica tomar com água é
coerente Isso sim é totalmente coerente
não tem nenhum problema Apesar dela ser
uma vitamina lipossolúvel não tem
nenhuma
inconsistência em relação a se tomar com
água Ok porque geralmente as pessoas não
vão tomar um suplemento com azeite de
oliva não vão tomar isso com óleo de
coco geralmente vão tomar com água mesmo
ok e agora para você começar a digerir
tá a benfotiamina você precisa de água
para você engolir é só isso
tá então ela vai ser dissolvida e
processado no intestino antes de ser
convertido na formativa então precisa de
água para isso é simples assim
além disso a águaa Vai facilitar a
passagem da benfotiamina através da
mucose intestinal certo Então apesar de
ser lipossolúvel então não tem nenhuma
consistência em relação a isso
não outra pergunta fora de padrão o
vinagre de maçã diluído em água antes do
almoço sempre provocou um desconforto
como também em outro horário uso suco
forte de limão diluído um dia adicionei
uma e outras vezes Duas colheres de
vinagre de maçã no suco de limão a
surpresa é que não houve nenhum
desconforto absolutamente tranquilo pode
estar havendo alguma reação
neutralização nessa mistura que para mim
pareceu se tornar
neutro bem interessante eu nunca tinha
receb pergunta
tá não nós sabemos que o vinagre de maçã
e o suco de limão são ambos altamente
ácidos né quando você consome eles
separadamente eles podem causar
desconforto também por conta de Asia
refluxo irritação de estômago porque
refluxo tem aí uns 60% de pessoas T
refluxo por falta de ao no estômago e
você vai ter uns 40% aí com refluxo que
é por deficiência da válvula anatômica
né e não é por falta de ASO por
deficiência da válvula então nessas
pessoas que TM deficiência de válvula o
refluxo pode acontecer sim né por conta
de excesso de áo no estômago Ok em
algumas circunstâncias
Então quando você mistura vinagre de
massa com suco de limão especialmente
diluído em água pode acontecer uma
interação entre os dois ácidos né o
ácido do vinagre com do suco de
limão e isso pode acontecer um efeito de
tamponamento tá de bufferização ao
tamponamento esses ácidos podem se
neutralizar parcialmente isso pode
diminuir a acidez Por uma questão aí de
interação entre os
ácidos e além disso o suco de limão
embora ácido ele também contém vitamina
C e outros compostos que podem ajudar na
digestão e na sensação de
saciedade tomar cuidado lembrar que
tanto o vinagre de maçã quanto o suco de
limão podem causar problemas da dentina
né no esmalte dentário então tomar
cuidado tomar de canudinho ok
não deixa eu tirar aqui do da tela as
indicações Obrigado pelo resposta do
volume tá
legal tá até alto aqui vou baixar o
volume beleza mas não tá distorcendo o
áudio não
né não tá distorcendo o áudio não
Roberta eu já respondo suas dúvidas ao
vivo tá deixa eu só terminar o documento
aí eu volto aqui ao vivo
Doutor Surgiu uma discussão no grupo a
respeito de alguns valores de exames que
nos deixou com dúvidas do que poderia
ser não é uma consulta individual é uma
dúvida quanto que poderia causar aqueles
valores insulina de quatro hemoglobina
glicada de seis glicemia matinal 97 e um
paciente 70 anos de idade seria possível
falência do pâncreas então esses
números indicam que provavelmente esse
esse pâncreas não vou dizer em falência
mas ele deve tá cansado tá Por que que
eu falo isso porque para uma glicemia de
97 Eu esperaria uma insulina de 15 de 20
tá um paciente em jejum Então esse
paciente provavelmente está fazendo uma
falência de células Beta pancreáticas
mas não é uma falência Total pode ser
uma só uma falência ainda Inicial tá é o
que parece agora certeza absoluta não dá
para saber é só uma suposição uma
um palpite meu baseado nesses números
que você tá apresentando aí mas com
certeza tem resistência insulínica pré
diabetes e pode já tá com uma uma
falência de células Beta de
início
Ok não é uma pergunta apenas sugestão
sugestão são sempre muito bem-vindas né
E essa
sugestão é
de quem que mandou sugestão deixa eu ver
aqui
do Fernando
né o último vídeo onde o senhor fez uma
interpretação de exame Laboratorial TSH
T3 Liv T4 livre com possível diagnóstico
soluções foi um formato de vídeo que
talvez chame mais atenção do público
Espero que sim seria legal ter outros
vídeos no mesmo formato resultado de
exame Laboratorial possível diagnóstico
possível suplementos então isso daí faz
muito sucesso no Instagram tá eu nunca
pensei em fazer nesse
formato dentro do YouTube mas eu acho
que eu vou começar a fazer Tá bom eu vou
acho acho que eu vou seguir a sua
sugestão vamos ver como é que vai ficar
a resposta desse vídeo né se a resposta
for boa eu vou ficar ainda mais animado
para fazer de novamente nesse
formato Doutor já vários vídeos
especialistas sugerindo que as
margarinas de hoje são feitas com óleos
saudáveis bons para o coração que são
diferentes das margarina de alguns anos
atrás é golpe de marketing mesmo ou
mudou a composição do produto testei
semana passada e as formigas continuam
nem chegando perto da margarina bem É o
seguinte essas manteigas novas não TM
mais a gordura trans Tá mas eles colocam
uma outra gordura que é inter
esterificada inter esterificada né Dá
até para treinar trava língua essa
gordura Inter esterificada é uma gordura
também artificial Ok e essa orora que
eles usam óleos vegetais que são é ricos
em ácidos polinsaturados problema que é
rico em omega6 e tem essa adição da
gordura Inter esterificada eu não usaria
margarina de nenhum tipo tá eu acho que
a margarina infelizmente não é confiável
Eu prefiro a gordura saturada da
manteiga ok
Existe algum suplemento que seja
indicado antes ou depois de fazer o
implante diário sim você pode estar
usando vitamina D para melhorar o
sucesso do implante né a consolidação do
osso em volta do implante a vitamina K2
mk7 também vai ajudar para que haja uma
recuperação dessa ósseo integração né
que é integração do implante no osso em
volta manter os seus níveis de cálcio
adequado de
magnésio de cobre de zinco de fósforo de
boro né que são os minerais que o osso
USA
a vitamina C pode ajudar também como
antioxidante melhorar a cicatrização por
causa que ela ajuda no
colágeno e que mais a cúrcuma pode
ajudar com antiinflamatório
pósoperatório para facilitar a
cicatrização a bosuer serrata também
Seria uma
boa então essa Essas são as minhas
sugestões o colágeno hidrolizado Tipo
dois também acho que seria uma boa e o
MSE
metil sulfanil
metano licorice junto com o rodiola rosa
pode regular o cortisol sim o licorice
ele tem uma substância chamada
glicerina essa glicerina ela inibe uma
enzima chamada 11 Beta hidrox esteroide
desidrogenase tipo do essa enzima
responsável converter o cortisol na
forma
inativa Ok então quando você usa a
glicirrizina do licorice ele aumenta os
níveis circulantes de
cortisol então ele vai aumentar o
cortisol para quem tem cortisol baixo Ok
então ele pode também aumentar pressão
arterial tem que tomar cuidado com o
licorice se você for usar o licorice pro
estômago tem que usar a fórmula do
licorice dgl que a sem a glicer isina a
rodiola rósea ela não tem um efeito
direto sobre o do cortisol como é o caso
da do licorice mas ela ela ajuda a
reduzir a resposta do cortisol ao
estresse
Ok então ela vai ajudar mais no cérebro
do que na adrenal ela tem efeitos
antioxidantes anti aliás neuroprotetores
vai ajudar a melhorar a performance
mental tá então realmente essa
combinação pode ser uma boa sim
no caso de cirurgia é necessário
suspender K2 Nat kinase Nat kinase
suspenderia uma semana antes da cirurgia
K2 Depende se você tiver tomando até 100
microg de K2 por dia não precisaria
suspender Mas se você tivesse tomando
uma dose alta de K2 tipo 300 microgramas
Eu suspenderia também uma semana antes
da da intervenção
tá porque a K2 em altas dos ela tem o
mesmo
efeito
né do da então isso pode aumentar até a
coagulação sanguínea enquanto a canato
kinase ela vai ter efeito anticoagulante
tá então na dúvida é melhor suspender
todo o suplemento uma semana antes da
cirurgia Tá bom mas no caso da calor se
for até 100 microg eu não vejo porque
suspender
não sabemos que os valores dos exam de
sangue se alteram de acordo com o tempo
de jejum para medir os triglicérides em
pessoa que não tem excesso de
triglicerídeos no sangue o jej de 8
horas dará um resultado
correto então Eh é bom que você faça o
jejum pelo menos 8 horas tá mas se você
ficar muitas horas de jejum pode
acontecer o contrário você pode ter um
resultado de triglicerido baixo mas ser
um valor
irreal porque você ficou mais de 12
horas de jejum Então acho que o jejum de
8 a 12 horas é o é o correto tá 8 horas
já é o suficiente mas não passar de 12
horas para não dar um result
resultado baixo demais
OK é importante também que a alimentação
nos dias anteriores do exame seja uma
alimentação que reflita o que a pessoa
geralmente para ter assim um resultado
mais Fit Digno entendeu nem comer eh
restrito demais que não seja uma
realidade pra pessoa e nem exagerar na
gordura
também próxima pergunta por que que o
mamão é considerada como uma fruta que
auxilia no o trabalho do intestino em
pessoas um pouco constipadas porque ela
tem fibras né uma mão ela vai ter fibras
que vão ser interessantes aí pro o
movimento
intestinal ela tem algumas substâncias
também que acaba soltando um pouco o
intestino fora a fibra ela tem a papaína
que é uma enzima proteolítica que ajuda
a quebrar proteína no
intestino as sementes do mamão também
tem a ação antiparasitária e também é
nutritivo tem fibras tem proteínas tem
minerais importantes como magnésio o
ferro ajuda nesse caso a as
feses mas o mamão pode ser uma fruta
problemática para quem tem pré-diabetes
ou resten suíca tá então tem que ficar
de olho nisso
daí e se a pessoa tiver um cibo ela pode
ter excesso de gases por conta do uso de
mamão Tá e isso
pode causar um problema
Quais exames de sangue se pode fazer
para avaliação da função pancreática
quando o único sintoma é baixa produção
de insulina não sintoma uma baixa
produção de insulina não é sintoma né
Isso aí é um resultado de exame e a
glicose já alcançando valores para
início de diabetes em pacientes com
alimentação controlado sem processados
industrializados e não consumidor de
álcool não glicemia de jejum a insulina
de jejum o indoma Né que é uma uma
medida que compara a Glicemia com a
insulina Ok peptídeo C também quando ele
tá aumentado o peptídeo c no sangue é
sinal de que o pâncreas está começando a
entrar em falência também
tá e eu não gosto desse exame mas tem o
teste de tolerância glicos que você
ingere lá o o suquinho super doce e aí
acompanha como é que tá o a sua glicemia
e insulina ao longo aí de vários minutos
meia hora 60 minutos 2 horas tá eu acho
esse exame muito complicado porque é um
é um exame que induz a resistência
insulínica
ultrassom abdominal total sem alterações
e também assintomático informação que
complementa essa pergunta baixo já feita
hoje Quais exames de sangue se pode
fazer para avaliar a função pancreática
quando único é já respondi isso aqui
né TDH tem
cura depende tá o TDH ele pode ter cura
sim se a pessoa tiver
realmente numa fase difícil tiver com
Muita ansiedade muito estresse isso tá
alterando a atividade e causando também
e falta de atenção e uma suposta TDH que
na verdade é um estresse que tá se
travestido de TDH
Ok mas para pessoas que tem um TDH
clássico ele pode ser na verdade é
controlado e não curado
Então na verdade é como a hipertensão
arterial você consegue controlar mas não
curar
E acho que o exemplo que eu dei não foi
muito bom tem caso de hipertensão leral
que a gente consegue curar assim 50% mas
outros 50% a gente não cura então TDH
seria mais nessa linha aí de a gente
conseguir reverter e controlar mas não
curar no sentido de toma um remédio uma
semana depois para e a pessoa não tem
mais problema tá
essa que foi a última pergunta Deixa eu
fazer responder as perguntas da da
Roberta Melo
aqui primeira pergunta aqui meu filho de
16 anos tem alguns fios de cabelo branco
tem alguma vitamina que ele possa tomar
sim você pode dar um metilfolato para
ele você pode dar também enzimas
antioxidantes no caso da catalase o sódi
Né que é superox dismutase do melão né
Tem tem aquele só de do melão mais a
catalase e o metilfolato isso vai ajudar
o cabelo dele ganhar cor de
novo estou com Gama GT super alto além
do colesterol Você conhece alguma
limpeza hepática de três dias não eu
conheço o protocolo do de detox é pato
biliar né do Moritz do Andreas Moritz
que são 7 dias é três dias esse
protocolo eu não conheço mas você pode
usar C Marina também
né o link do formulário e da Live não
estão aparecendo é não coloquei no no
YouTube não Antônio foi falha minha tá
eu coloquei só no o grupo do do WhatsApp
foi falha minha
mesmo você quer que coloque agora vai
fazer diferença colocar
agora ele também está com queda el deve
estar estressado né Roberta
provavelmente Doutor Você pode me
explicar de novo sobre o teste de
intolerância alimentar tipo se deu que a
pessoa é incompatível ela suspende por
uns dias suspende por três semanas eh os
alimentos pode ser de três a qu semanas
tá depois pode comer eventualmente
depende Então você paraar o alimento
suspeito por três a quro
semanas e aí reintroduz em doses baixas
no primeiro dia eu Come bem pouquinho no
segundo dia um pouquinho mais no
terceiro dia eu come mais se der alguma
reação passou mal sentiu mal estar
sentiu algum problema na pele sentiu
diarreia sentiu qualquer coisa diferente
é porque aquele alimento realmente vai
ter que manter ele penso aí você pode
ficar tipo TRS meses sem comer aquilo lá
e fazer uma segunda tentativa de
reintrodução se a segunda tentativa for
bem sucedida ótimo aí você pode voltar
com meu alimento se deu problema de novo
então aí eu suspenderia definitivamente
esse alimento
beleza eu fiz uma pergunta no formulário
agora não precisa não
obrigado mas qual foi essa pergunta foi
sugestão eu já assisti vídeos no YouTube
Deixa eu ver se esse aqui é o seu agora
eu não sei se aqui é o seu me dá só um
minutinho
aqui no individual aqui pera
aí pera aí
mas ter que passar assim é chato né
Vamos lá
demora 20 21
Ah é
Antônio beleza eu já assisti vídeos no
YouTube em que os tópicos depois dos
vídeos estão divididos em tópicos com
respectivo tema com Não isso aí já faz
há muito tempo já isso Antônio a já faz
essa divisão em minutos é porque a gente
ficava na dúvida se isso era bom ou ruim
porque que que isso muitas vezes is
provoca né a pessoa acaba não vendo o
vídeo inteiro isso prejudica a retenção
porque ela quer só ir naquele minuto que
tem a resposta que ela quer entendeu Mas
já fez várias vezes isso daí E é feito
por inscrito aparentemente mas já vi os
criadores também fazendo não sei como
vocêes conseguem não é fácil de fazer
isso aí não é difícil não tá bom isso
não é difícil de fazer não só porque
assim isso por um lado atrapalha também
tá porque a pessoa só vai naquele minuto
que quer assistir não ver o vídeo
inteiro é isso pro YouTube não é legal
YouTube não quer que a pessoa assista só
um pedaço do vídeo
e qual a dosagem do qu
Roberta violato 1 MG
tá 1 MG por
dia qual é o protocolo para fazer
limpeza não do andr não tem como passa
agora aqui não ele é meio complicadinho
tá eu posso passar depois o protocolo no
grupo mas não é o de três dias não
protocolo de 7 dias
tá Não precisa se desculpar Antônio Se
você olhar lá os vídeos do YouTube mais
antigo você vai ver que tem vários deles
que tem essa marcação aí que você tá
falando Tá bom mas não precisa se
desculpar
[Música]
não vou comer um pouquinho aqui tá
pessoal só um
minutinho deixa eu achar o o Andrés
murit você tá falando do livro do Andrés
muritz ou Denise
deixa eu achar
aqui já mostro para vocês
aqui aqui
achei deixa eu mostrar ah
[Música]
aqui ó tá dando para
ver posso mandar no grupo para vocês
darem uma olhada se vocês quiserem
C
[Música]
vou mandar lá no grupo agora
vai não deu
certo tentar de novo
aqui
ué que estranho
ah tentar de um outro jeito aqui
R pronto per fui
mais perguntas pessoal só vou terminar
de comer aqui o meu lanchinho
C
[Música]
perdão pessoal termi de comer
aqui qued de cabelo em jovem com menos
de 30 anos masculino geralmente na mente
integrativa
é reversível na maioria dos casos é é
reversível na maioria dos casos sim a
não ser que seja uma lopa androgenética
muito
intensa
é a primeira vez que participo queria
saber como é que funciona para saber as
respostas para saber as respostas
precisa fazer as perguntas como é que
você faz a
pergunta toda segunda-feira vai lá no
grupo do WhatsApp o link com o
formulário que você preenche para fazer
as perguntas você pode preencher o
formulário várias vezes se você quiser
para várias perguntas tá
bom viu Roberta você tá lá no grupo do
WhatsApp Dr Alan Eu também Geralmente eu
publico também no no YouTube é que nas
últimas duas semanas eu eu falei de
publicar o link das perguntas no
YouTube Dr Alan o senhor acha que esse
protocolo do morit pode ser bom para
diminuir a gordura no fígado pode ajudar
agora sozinho não vai resolver não o que
vai realmente ajudar a resolver isso é
mudança
alimentar cortando um carboidrato
refinado
processado alimentos industrializados em
geral
né OK mais perguntas pessoal
a gente a gente chegou discutir artigo
semana passada não tô
lembrado deixa eu ver
aqui eu acho que a gente não discutiu
porque teve muita pergunta semana
passada
Antônio Renato agradeço muito pela sua
disponibilidade de
nada Roberta como é que você entrou no
grupo do WhatsApp desculpa no grupo de
apoiadores você não entrou pelo YouTube
Então quando você se inscreve como
apoiadora aparece um link
né aparece um link lá que dá acesso ao
grupo do WhatsApp
tá
eh eu vou fazer o seguinte então eu vou
colocar o link aqui ã deixa eu achar
esse link só
minuto para você entrar no no no
WhatsApp só achar aqui
ah
grupo não
mess aqui
deixa eu
copiar ó o
link é esse aqui
[Música]
tá coloca lá em dutra.com
b1752 4
tá aí você vai entrar no no grupo do
WhatsApp
copia isso daí no papel
Roberta tá bom E aí você digita no no
Browser E aí você vai entrar diretamente
no grupo do Então você digita no celular
mesmo entra no Chrome no celular e aí
você digita isso daí Aí você vai entrar
no grupo acho que se você não tiver
WhatsApp web é mais fácil pelo celular
ok bem eu vou falar só um artigu inho
aqui para vocês e a gente vai encerrar a
Live tá
bom aproveitando a pergunta sobre TDH
tem um estudo
interessante é um estudo que avaliou se
os probióticos poderiam ajudar o
tratamento do TDH que é o transtorno de
Déficit de Atenção e
hiperatividade no caso o grupo estudado
foram crianças então é um estudo de um
grupo de pesquisadores em Taiwan que
avaliou
essa suplementação com a Cepa probiótica
bífido bacterium
bífido Mais especificamente o bf
688 Teria algum efeito positivo em
criança com TDH o objetivo principal era
Observar se haveria melhorias no
sintomas de desatenção e
hiperatividade além de mudança no
desempenho neuropsicológico e nas
medidas
antropométricas como peso índice massa
corporal então o estudo contou com 102
crianças com idades entre 7 e 9 anos né
A idade média era 9 anos sendo 87
meninos e 15
meninas todas essas crianças já estavam
em tratamento medicamentoso com TDH né
tomando ritalina tomando outros
medicamentos com dosagem estável há pelo
menos qu
semanas então isso garantiu que Qualquer
mudança observada pudesse atribuída Com
mais confiança a suplementação
probiótica então ao longo de 12 semanas
os participantes foram se divididos em
dois grupos um grupo recebeu diariamente
5 bilhões de unidades fumadoras de
colônia né 5 bilhões de UFC dessa Cepa
do bif bactério bifidum BF 688 e quantra
outro grupo recebi o placeto que a pío
de farinha então durante o período de
estudo foi solicitado que mantivessem os
hábitos alimentares estilo de vida
normal habitual então não melhoraram os
atos de vida né queriam só avaliar se o
probiótico junto com o remédio para TDH
e acrescentar mais algum benefício Então
as avaliações aconteceram no início do
estudo com quatro semanas 8 e 12
semanas Então os resultados foram os
seguintes os sintomas de TDH melhoraram
Em ambos os grupos ao longo do tempo mas
não houve diferença significativa
entre aqueles que tomaram probiótico e
os que receberam Placebo Então bora um
grupo que tomou o bf 688 né o probiótico
tem mostrado algumas melhoras
específicas em testes neuropsicológicos
eles consideraram que as diferenças não
foram estatisticamente significativas se
comparadas ao
Placebo Além disso apesar de algumas
mudanças na composição da microbiota
intestinal que observadas apenas no
grupo que tomou probiótico Então teve
uma mudança realmente na Flora segundo
Esse estudo isso não se traduziu em
benefícios clínicos Claros então é
importante destacar que houve algumas
inconsistências entre os resultados
pré-registo sobre possíveis vieses na
divulgação dos resultados isso lembra
nós da importância
na transparência na pesquisa científica
da necessidade de interpretar os estudos
com
cautela então uma coisa interessante eu
gostaria de ver os resultados desse
estudo em crianças não tomando ritalina
né Não tomando metilfenidato Não tomando
as drogas comuns para essa
doença então segundo a conclusão desse
estudo embora a ideia de usar
probióticos para ajudar no manejo TDH é
interessante eu usaria sempre mas usaria
em conjunto com r teanina com magnésio
com zinco uma série de outras coisas né
Esse estudo em específico não encontrou
evidências significativas em termos
estatísticos de que essa ca do bifido
bacterium bifidum BF
688 traria benefícios clínicos
significativos para crianças com TDH Eu
discordo porque na verdade o que que
deveria fazer fazer uma abordagem
integrada né não só o probiótico
probiótico ajuda mas sozinho realmente
seria muito fraco
ok ok então eu vou eu vou deixar o outro
artigo para discutir na semana que vem
no dia
19 tem mais perguntas ao vivo que eu vou
encerrar depois dessas duas o uso
exacerbado de PC celular e sono
irregular pode simular TDH pode Sem
dúvida Antônio dormir fora de hora por
exemplo a partir das 2 horas até às 10 2
da manhã quer dizer né fora de hora pelo
fato de dormir mais de 8 horas compensa
não não compensa totalmente não porque o
pessoal geralmente depois das 8 horas da
manhã esse sono depois das 8 horas da
manhã tem muito barulho muita luz
interfere com o sono tá eh at diria até
depois das 7 horas da manhã então esse
som não acaba sendo muito compensatório
não é verdade que o sou noturno tem que
pegar um horário antes da meia-noite sim
porque as horas antes da meia-noite tem
um valor mais alto do que as horas
depois da meia noite isso isso é verdade
sim tá então se você puder dormir às 10
horas da noite é melhor ou no máximo as
o ômega-3 indicado na Live passada é ele
eh e cada cápsula uma dose Ou tem que
ser duas eu não lembro agora qual foi
que eu indiquei na Live passada mas
geralmente é duas ou três cápsulas tá
duas ou três cápsulas para compor a dose
padrão do ômega-3 tá nunca uma cápsula é
muito difícil ser uma cápsula só a não
ser que seja ômega-3 muito muito
concentrado tá hoje o Antônio Renato
está fazendo um papel do Eliseu
davita for depende aqui a Vita for tem
mais de uma apresentação se for aquele
super ômega3 da vita fora são duas
cápsulas tá agora se for
ômega3 habitual aí são três beleza
Antônio Renato ele incorporou o Eliseu
hoje Eliseu faltou aí o espírito elão
entrou no Ton renal Tô brincando viu tá
bem pessoal tá bom
né então semana que vem a gente continua
essa conversa
aqui eu acho engraçado que eu convidei
já várias vezes alguns de vocês a entrar
comigo ao vivo né mas vocês são muito
tímidos Vocês são muito tímidos vocês
não querem entrar ao vivo né
bem pessoal obrigado pela presença de
vocês deus abençoe a todos vocês Roberta
conseguiu entrar lá no grupo do WhatsApp
Roberto conseguiu deu tempo vou esperar
você responder para poder
sair Denise vai Antônio vai Antônio o
quê Ah sim Gol Antônio Gol Deve ser isso
né Paz e Luz Para você também Reinaldo
conseguiu Roberta
consegui entrar lá no
grupo Ah tá bom tá esperando terminar a
Live Então tá bom beijo no coração de
vocês até a próxima